Undoubtedly one of the modern history's most notorious and abhorrent his crimes
that the stuff of nightmares over the course of 13 years,
he prowls for men and load them back to his house before drugging them and
strangling them and all you took the lives of 17 men between 1978 and 1991,
but simply killing his victims wasn't enough for Jeffrey Dahmer.
He never wanted them to leave,
so he saved several trophies,
including severed heads.
Eventually even eight parts of the victims don't always captured in 1991 and
sentenced to 16 lifetimes here was killed by a fellow prison inmates,
Christopher Scarborough in 1994.
And in today's video we're taking a look at the serial killers dark life.
Jeffrey Dahmer was born on May the 21st 1960 in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin to Lionel,
enjoy stanhope.
He was described by his mother was a beautiful baby and both parents considered
him to be a normal child,
but as teachers they saw them differently.
At least one.
His first grade teacher wondered if Jeffrey was neglected at home and noted that
he was a reserved child on his report card.
In truth,
both of Jeffrey's parents didn't spend a lot of time with him when Jeffrey was
young.
His father was in college earning a chemistry degree and Jeffrey's mother was
often bedridden,
recovering from illnesses.
His parents had a tumultuous marriage that he later described as extreme tension
from the constant arguing Italian,
yet there was no doubt Lionel and Joyce Dahmer love their son and tried to do
the best for him when he was six years old where I Jeffrey might not take well
to a new baby brother.
They let him pick out his name.
Jeffrey named his younger brother David.
The Donner family moved a few times before eventually settling in bath in Ohio
in 1968.
If there were any red flags that indicated future violence in the young Jeffrey,
it was this fascination with animal bones and how they fit together.
The interest in caucuses began when he was four years old.
Once a Jeffrey was helping his father,
clear animal remains from under the house,
and Jeffrey was oddly thrilled by the sound of the boons dropping into the metal
buckets he lays.
It began collecting them,
searching in ditches and along streets for roadkill.
He began dismembering the bodies behind the house in a patch of wooded area,
installed the various body parts in John's in the families woodshed.
On one occasion,
Jeffrey decapitated the corpse of a dog before nailing the body to a tree when
he was 10 years old.
So over dinner,
Jeffrey asked his father what would happen if chicken bones were placed in each
line or a chemist interpreted his son's question,
is miss scientific curiosity?
And he took the opportunity to teach your son about the proper way to clean and
to preserve his collections.
Jeffrey later admitted that the age of 14 that he experiencing sexual
compulsion.
He designed boys,
not girls,
and these sexual fantasies involved submission,
violence and death.
He began drinking as a teenager to suppress his urges and didn't talk to anyone
about the disturbing thoughts that he was having.
At the age of 16,
he fantasized about raping a jogger.
He saw regularly and plans to attack the man one day,
Jeffrey Land Way to the baseball bats and the bushes along the man's regular
route.
The man didn't come by that day and Jeffrey never attempted to carry it out
again.
I revere high school.
Most of his classmates thought of Diana as an outcast with few friends.
Some were troubled by his heavy drinking.
They drunk both and beer and liquor at school,
so I'm going,
it's inside the lining of his army.
Fatigue jacket,
his grades one average,
and then took a dive as his drinking spun out of control in 1977.
He played clarinet briefly and abandoned was a decent tennis player.
Overall,
his teachers observe Jeffrey is a polite and quiet boy,
although he was awkward,
he regularly amused as classmates by staging pranks such as acting out seizures,
knocking over items,
and making loud and obnoxious noises.
The banks were so popular that similar behavior was referred to as doing a
Dhamma by the end of high school of parents,
troubled marriage.
She finally came to an end after an unsuccessful attempt at counseling in early
1978 line or moved out of the house dominant.
Graduated in May of that same year.
A few weeks after graduation.
Dharma committed his first murder when he picked up a hitchhiker 18 year old
Steven Marks was on his way to a rock concert when Donna Lord him back to his
house to hang out and drink a few beers before the show.
My now dominant lived alone as his parents,
his house,
his mother moved out with younger brother David while his father took up
residence at the local motel x and diamond.
Spent a few hours together listening to music and drinking when I was ready to
leave dominant,
didn't want him to so he struck him in the head with a 10 pound dumbbell and
strangled him to death.
While Hicks was unconscious,
he then proceeded to masturbate over his body,
moved him to the crawlspace under the house,
and they selected as body before burying it in a shallow grave.
Several weeks later,
Diana on Earth,
Texas,
body the flesh from the bones and dissolve this an asset.
He crushed his bones with a sledge hammer and sprinkled them in the woodlot
behind the house.
A short time later,
diamonds father visited his son and learns that he was living alone.
He moved back into the house and convinced to Diana to enroll in college.
Diamond spent three months at Ohio State University before dropping out in early
of 1979 at the urging of his father,
he joined the US army dominant,
served as a combat medic in Germany,
but it's performance deteriorated due to his drinking.
He was honorably discharged in March of 1981,
at least two soldiers later or tested that diamond rapes them while in the
service.
One thing that has happened repeatedly over the course of 17 months and the
other exams that diamond drugged him
following his discharge,
Donna returned home to Ohio state only a brief time.
He was arrested for disorderly conduct which prompted his father to arrange for
dominance.
He lived with his grandmother in Wisconsin is alcoholism continued and he was
arrested for indecent exposure.
He was arrested again in 1986 when to boys' accused him of masturbating in front
of them.
In September of 1987,
Dama took his second victim viceman with Steven to amy.
According to Donna,
he has no memory of killing to amy.
They have checked into a hotel room together and drank heavily,
and Donald woke in the morning and discovered the body next to him.
Dama bought a large suitcase to transport two Emmys,
remains to his grandmother's basement,
were dismembered and masturbated over the corpse,
so for disposing of the remains only after dominic kills another two victims of
his grandmother's home,
did she tire of his late nights in his drunkenness.
She had no knowledge of his other activities and forced them to move out of the
premises.
In 1988,
that September of 1988 Dahmer had an extremely lucky escape and encounter with a
13 year old Laotian by resulted in charges of sexual exploitation and second
degree sexual assault for diamond.
He pled guilty claiming that the boy had appeared much older while awaiting
sentencing for the sexual assault case.
Dahmer again,
put his grandmother's basement to a gruesome use.
In March of 1989,
he learned drugged,
strangled,
sodomized,
photographed,
dismembered,
and disposed of Antony caesars and aspiring model at his trial for child
molestation.
In 1989,
Dima was the model of contrition.
He argued eloquently in his own defense about how he had seen the error of his
ways and that his arrest marked a turning point in his life.
His defense counsel argued that he needed treatment,
not incarceration,
and the judge agreed handing down a one year prison sentence on day release,
allowing dumber to work his job during the day and to return to prison at night
as well as handing down a five year probationary sentence.
Years later in an interview with CNN line or dominant,
stated that he wrote a letter to the court that issued that sentence requesting
psychological help before his son's parole.
However,
Jeffrey Dahmer was granted an early release by the judge off to serving only 10
months of a sentence.
He briefly lived with his grandmother following has released during which time
he does not appear to added to his body counts before moving back into his own
apartment over the following years.
Dom is victim counts,
accelerated,
bringing his total from four to 17.
He developed rituals as he progressed,
experimented with mechanical means of disposal,
and often consuming flesh of his victims.
Dama are also attempted crew to the bottom is drilling into victim skulls while
they were still alive and injecting them with Muriatic assets.
He was careful to select victims on the fringes of society who were often
itinerants or borderline criminal,
making their disappearances less noticeable and reducing the likelihood of his
capture as the murders piled up.
Adama was still unsatisfied.
He stated later I was completely swept along with my own compulsion.
I don't know how else to put it.
It didn't satisfy me completely,
so maybe I was thinking maybe another one will maybe this one will and the
numbers started growing and growing and just got out of control.
As you can see on May the 27th,
19,
91.
Dom Is Neda.
Sandra Smith called the police to report that an Asian boy was running naked in
the streets when the police arrived,
the boy was incoherence and they accepted the word of dimer,
a wise man living in a largely poor African American community that the boy was
his 19 year old lover.
In fact,
the boy was 14 years old and he was the brother of the 14 year old teen that
Donna had previously molested the police escorted dahmer and the boy home and
cleaning,
not wishing to become embroiled in a homosexual domestic disturbance,
took only accustomed to look around before leaving.
Once the police left the scene,
Donna killed the boy and proceeded with his usual rituals are they conducted
even a basic search,
police officers would've found the body of dominance.
Twelfth Victim Tony Hughes before he was finally arrested on July the 22nd 1991,
he killed for more manual.
Dom is cunning.
Spree ended when he was arrested on July the 22nd 1991 that day to Milwaukee.
Police officers picked up Tracy Edwards,
a 32 year old African American man who was wandering the streets with a
headscarf dangling from his wrist.
They decided to investigate the man's claims that we dude had drugged and
restrained him.
They arrived at domus apartments where he commonly offered to get the keys for
the handcuffs.
Edwards claimed the knife dahmer had threatened him with was in the bedroom,
and the officer went in to corroborate the story.
He noticed a polaroid photographs of dismembered bodies lying around.
It was at that point that Donna was subdued by the officers.
Subsequent searches revealed a heads in the refrigerator,
three more in the freezer and the catalog of other horrors including preserved
skulls.
John's containing jenise Eylea and an extensive gallery of macabre polaroid
photographs if its victims.
Dom is refrigerator and polaroid photographs became inextricably associated with
his notorious killing spree.
In 1996 following dominance death,
a group of Milwaukee businessman raised more than $400,000 to purchase the items
that he used for his victims,
including blades,
source,
handcuffs,
and a refrigerator to store the body parts.
They promptly destroyed them in an effort to distance the city from the horrors
of dom,
his actions,
and the ensuing media circus that surrounded his trial.
Jeffrey dom is trial began in January of 1992,
given that the majority of dominance victims were African American.
There were considerable racial tensions and say strict security precautions were
taken,
including an eight foot barrier of bulletproof glass that separated him from the
gallery.
The inclusion of only one African American on the jury provoked further unrest,
but was ultimately contains.
It's very short lived well.
I know Donna and to second wife attended the trial throughout dahmer initially
pled not guilty to all charges despite having confessed to the killings during
police interrogation,
but he eventually changed his plea to guilty by virtue of insanity.
His defense then offered the gruesome details of his behavior as proof that only
someone truly insane which commit assumption terrible acts.
Donna later said in an interview,
it's hard for me to believe that a human being could have done what I've done,
but I know that I did it.
The jury chose to believe the prosecutions of sessions,
that dom was fully aware that his acts were evil and that he chose to commit
them anyway.
On February the 15th,
19,
92,
they returned after approximately 10 hours deliberation to find him guilty but
sane on all accounts.
He was sentenced to 15 consecutive lifetimes in prison with 16th,
10 tacked on in May.
It is now over.
This has never been the case of trying to get free.
I didn't ever want freedom,
but this was a case to tell the world that I did what I did,
but not for reasons of hate.
I hated no one.
I knew I was sick or evil or both.
Now I believe I was sick.
The doctors have told me about my sickness and now I have some peace.
I know how much high of cost.
Thank God.
There will be no more harm that I can do.
I believe that I the Lord Jesus Christ can save me from my sins.
I ask for no consideration.
Dominant reportedly adjusted well to prison life,
although he was initially kept apart from the general population.
He eventually convinced the authorities to allow him to integrate more fully
with the other inmates.
He found religion in the form of books and photos sent to him by his father and
he was granted permission by the Columbia Correctional Institution to be
baptized by a local pastor
on November the 28th,
19,
94 in accordance with this inclusion in regular work details.
Donna was assigned to work with two other convicted murderers,
Jesse Anderson and Christopher Askava after they had been left alone to complete
that task sconce or tend to find the discover had brutally beaten both men with
a metal bar from the prison white room.
Donald was pronounced debt after approximately an hour and just succumbed to his
injuries days later in 2015.
Christopher Scott spoke to the New York Post about his reasons for killing.
Donna discover alleged that he was disturbed and not only buy diamonds crimes
but by our habits.
Donna had developed of fashioning severed limbs from prison food to antagonize
other inmates after being taunted by Dahmer and Anderson during their work
detail.
Scholar said that he confronted her about his crimes before beating the two men
to death.
He also claims that the prison guards allowed the merger to happen and dom is
will.
He requested that upon his death his body be cremated as soon as possible,
but some medical researches wanted just brain preserved so that it can be
studied.
Lionel Dahmer wanted to respect his son's wishes and cremate or remains.
His mother felt his brain should go to research.
The two parents went to court and the judge sided with Lionel.
After one year,
diamonds body was released and the remains were cremated as he requested in
August of 2012,
nearly two decades after his death.
It was reported that his childhood home and Botha,
Ohio,
where he committed his first murder in 1978 and buried his victims remains was
on the markets.
It's owner,
musician Chris Butler stated that the property would make a great time as long
as the buyer could get past the horror facts act in March of 2016,
Butler put the house up for rent for $8,000 for the week of the Republican
National Convention as of July 2017.
The house was no longer listed on the market according to Zillow,
so I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time.
Every Monday and Thursday we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
suffering from the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.